sales of disposable vapes are booming
multi-colored multi-flavored low-cost
highly addictive and crucially
disposable
they're very popular in moment i mean
it's so easy to consume and the flavors
are amazing they have so much so wide
variety of choice
but convenience comes at a price
particularly for the environment
research by sky news and the bureau of
investigative journalism reveals we're
buying around 168 million disposable
vapes each year in the uk
defra which is responsible for
electronic waste told us it's reviewing
its collection and recycling later this
year but for the time being over half of
those vapes end up going straight in the
bin
so what are we throwing away
with the help of a material scientist we
took a disposable vape apart
don't try this at home the vape liquid
is toxic
and the batteries can catch fire
this is one of those standard lithium
batteries that
are made by their in in their millions
most disposable vapes have a similar
size battery each contains less than 0.2
grams of lithium metal
that is obviously the material we all
need for electric cars all the renewable
energies their laptops your phones we've
all got this stuff in it
at least half of these are going in the
bin
how does how does that i mean that's
just so it's so awful isn't it
we can't be throwing these materials
away i mean it really is madness
madness because lithium isn't easy to
get hold of
[Applause]
here in chile for instance which
produces a quarter of the world's supply
it's extracted from vast brine pools
that have their own environmental impact
yet our research shows from disposable
vapes alone we're binning around 10
tonnes of lithium a year in the uk
enough to make batteries for 1200
electric cars
the environment agency told us it's
reviewing electronic waste recycling
rules later this year as for the
disposable vape companies
they're supposed to register themselves
ensure the return or recycling of their
products
it does suggest that more work needs to
be done in making sure that
new producers when you get a phenomenal
like this which suddenly a new type of
product is is seemingly everywhere
are probably being covered by the
regulations
we couldn't find either of the two most
popular brands on the register
and neither responded to our request for
comment
tom clark sky news